his labor day weekend in the valley is
experiencing a high volume of people
coming through even as the cdc warned
the unvaccinated to stay home
madison kimbrough is live at mccarran
with how visitors are feeling and what
they plan to do this holiday weekend
madison
las vegas continues and will always be a
hot spot destination as you can see
we're here at mccarran airport as
tourists are making their way through
baggage claim currently you can see it
is not filled up the people just left
and got their bags but we anticipate
that it is going to be a pretty big
turnout all through the evening right
now at mccarran we've seen a lot of
passengers arriving for the big holiday
weekend july was one of the busiest
months for mccarran airport since the
pandemic began with 3.3 million
passengers as for hotels august 2021
actually out passed
august of 2019 before the pandemic even
started despite the mass mandate and the
coveted variants people we talked to
couldn't wait to get here
it's been
probably two years since i've been here
in vegas and it was just an exciting
time to be able to get out and just
enjoy some time with friends it's crazy
i've never been here before and i'm kind
of sad that it like had to be like this
obviously you have to take like
precautions and just like be safe
nevada las vegas has been the top hotel
destination since the spring that's
followed by other west coast
destinations like anaheim san diego los
angeles and sacramento so as you can see
here at mccarran there's currently no
one at baggage claim but that is soon
going to change as flights are coming in
and as for roads really got to be on the
lookout for that across the valley
especially on the strip as construction
is very
and leave early reporting live madison
kimbrough 8 news now all right thanks
madison